[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi, and welcome.
We're here at the
security zone at Next
with Lorena Crowley from the
Google Cloud Security team.
Hi, Lorena.
LORENA CROWLEY: Hey, Yufeng.
YUFENG GUO: Lorena,
you're an expert
on ransomware attacks, which are
a common problem for companies.
Can you tell us more about it?
LORENA CROWLEY: You're right,
Yufeng, ransomware attacks
are a common problem for
companies far and wide.
A recent report
on malware attacks
showed that a company is hit
by a ransomware attack every 40
seconds.
And we're helping protect
employees and companies
from these attacks.
YUFENG GUO: So if
I'm a security admin,
I'm trying to protect my
company from ransomware attacks.
How should I approach it?
LORENA CROWLEY: The first
thing you need to do
is understand the way
ransom attackers work.
One of the most common
attack vectors for ransomware
is email.
As you can see, the attacker
sends phishing emails
with malicious malware attacks.
They're trying to
trick employees
into opening up these emails.
A second common attack
vector is website attacks.
Attackers embed
malicious malware
into websites that
look legitimate.
And employees may be
tricked into downloading
the malicious malware,
thinking it's something else.
YUFENG GUO: Wow, so whenever
employees are opening up
emails or browsing
the web, they could
be at risk of accidentally
downloading malware.
LORENA CROWLEY:
Unfortunately, yes.
And there's even other
sophisticated ransomware attack
vectors when attackers when try
to create new malware variants.
These new malware
variants are designed
to sneak by existing detectors
and perimeter defenses
that operating systems have.
So as a security admin trying to
protect against these attacks,
the first thing you
really need to do
is understand these vectors.
And then you need to
understand the business impacts
that successful ransomware
attacks can have.
Let's take a look
over here at a company
that has a lot of
ransomware vulnerabilities.
We're looking at a
company here that has
a lot of legacy
systems that haven't
been updated in a while.
Because of that, there are
several key vulnerabilities
that ransomware
attackers could exploit.
The first vulnerability
this company
has is a legacy
on-premise email server.
These servers that are the
gatekeepers for letting emails
into users' inboxes.
When ransomware attackers
send malicious emails
into the server, if the malware
detection in the email server
hasn't been updated
in a while, it's
going to be easier
for these emails
to get through to
users' inboxes.
YUFENG GUO: So what happens
when a user, say, opens
one of these malware files?
LORENA CROWLEY: Well,
when an employee opens up
one of these files, their
device is encrypted.
And they receive a message
on their screen demanding
a cryptocurrency payment before
the device is unencrypted.
The employee can't access any
of their apps or data, which
makes them unproductive.
And the company may
have to pay ransom
to get the device unencrypted.
But that's not it.
Another vulnerability
this company has
is that they're using an
out-of-date legacy browser.
When ransomware attackers
embed malware into websites,
these out-of-date browsers
aren't necessarily
able to detect them.
YUFENG GUO: So that
means you could just
have more employees getting
tricked into downloading
these files on websites.
LORENA CROWLEY: That's right.
The impact of an
out-of-date browser
could mean more successful
web-based malware
attacks in your organization.
If a company experiences a
lot of these different attacks
across their
different departments,
the costs and losses
in productivity
really start to add up.
One last vulnerability
this company has
is that it's running a
traditional operating
system that hasn't been updated
with the latest patches.
That means this OS
may let employees
run an executable
file that is risky.
So if an employee accidentally
downloads a malware file,
this operating
system isn't going
to do anything to stop it.
Ransomware attackers exploit
both known and unknown
vulnerabilities in
these operating systems
to lock users' systems down.
YUFENG GUO: Wow, so this legacy
company isn't doing so well.
LORENA CROWLEY: No.
Right now this
company is struggling.
They're suffering with
lower productivity,
and they even have ransom
payments to deal with.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, these
ransomware attacks
seem to be really able to
slow down the whole business.
LORENA CROWLEY: They really can.
YUFENG GUO: And so as a
security admin, how can I
help protect employees
and the business
from these sorts of attacks?
LORENA CROWLEY: Well,
I'm glad you asked that.
Why don't we go take a look
at another company that
is prepared to take these
ransomware attacks on?
This company is
using Google Cloud
to help protect employees
and their business
from the impact of
ransomware attacks.
They have multiple
layers of protection.
The first thing this company
is using to protect employees
is Gmail.
Gmail is a cloud-based
email service
that protects employees by
blocking ransomware emails
before they hit their inbox.
Gmail can automatically
detect even sophisticated
ransomware attacks by
identifying them within emails
and blocking them before
they hit a user's inbox.
So ransomware attacks can
be detected and blocked.
Why don't we take a look
at the second protection
this company has in place?
It's Chrome browser.
The Safe Browsing technology
in a Chrome browser
alerts users who may be
trying to visit a risky site.
As a security admin, you
can add additional controls.
For example, if you're
leveraging auto updates,
employees will have the
most up-to-date protection
available, even against
new malware variants.
And with additional protections
like sandboxing and site
isolation, if a user
does visit a risky site,
that malware won't spread
between tabs or processes.
YUFENG GUO: That's great.
So if an employee browses
to one of these sites,
they're going to get alerted.
LORENA CROWLEY: Right, and
they're going to be safe.
The last protection
we'll look at
is how this company is
using Chrome OS to protect
from ransomware attacks.
Chrome OS it is a
cloud-based operating system.
Because it runs in the
cloud, it prevents employees
from running executable files,
unlike traditional operating
systems.
So even if an employee downloads
a malicious malware file,
the operating system
blocks it from executing.
Chrome OS offers
additional safeguards,
things like auto
updates that help keep
employees completely protected.
YUFENG GUO: So as
a security admin,
these tools will
help businesses avoid
all kinds of these attacks.
LORENA CROWLEY: Exactly.
Between Gmail, Chrome
browser, and Chrome OS,
they're all working together
to help provide employees
and businesses the security
they need to stay productive
and to prevent them from paying
money to ransomware attackers.
YUFENG GUO: That is so great.
Thanks so much, Lorena, for
explaining how Google Cloud is
protecting companies
from ransomware attacks
all over the world.
LORENA CROWLEY: Thanks
for having me, Yufeng.